madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie est
libre en bourgogne une émission
consacrée aujourd'hui à la lutte contre
le chômage alors que le président de la
république doit présenter lundi son plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi
et alors que vendredi prochain robert
badinter présentera lui son rapport sur
le code du travail qui doit faire
l'objet d'une réforme au mois de mars
et puis parallèlement le sénat à adopter
cette semaine le projet territoire à
zéro chômeur de longue durée déjà voté
par l'assemblée nationale en décembre
dernier alors c'est de tout cela dont
nous voulons parler jusqu'à 12h20 avec
nos quatre invités laurent
grandguillaume bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député ps de côte-d'or et c'est vous qui
allez des fondus et porté le texte sur
ce fameux projet territoire zéro chômeur
catherine vandriesse jour vous êtes
conseillère régionale conseillère
municipale les républicains vous êtes
également chef d'entreprise
juliette de hoarau bonjour bonjour vous
êtes secrétaire régional à l'union
régionale interprofessionnelle cfdt
bourgogne en face de vous benoît ville
où tout nouveau président de la cgpme de
bourgogne franche comté
vous représentez déjà la cgpme pardon au
niveau de la côte d'or
bonjour bonjour à la maison je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez interpellé
directement nos invités via twitter
hashtag lvl bourgogne ou via notre page
facebook
alors pour introduire le propos un petit
tour de table sur ce fameux plan
d'urgence que doit présenter françois
hollande après demain le chef de l'état
allait aborder à cette question lors de
ses voeux à le 31 décembre
globalement les uns et les autres qu'est
ce que vous attendez des propositions du
président la république
moi ce que j'attendrais en fait en tout
cas de ces propositions c'est que l'on
puisse sortir des clivages traditionnels
trouver les voies durables pour faire
reculer ce fléau qu'est le chômage qui
touche le temps citoyen attend lyon le
dis depuis longtemps mais en fait le
problème c'est qu'on est souvent vous
savez dans l'ère de la glaciation des
clivages traditionnels
on ne veut pas aller
ou devant et on veut pas sortir de cette
image donc les uns s'affronte en
apparaissant comme des hypers libéraux
les autres contre les régulations liste
acharnée mais je suis sûr qu'il ya entre
ces deux positions des voies qui peuvent
permettre de converger et surtout de
faire reculer le chômage parce que c'est
ça dont on parle de nos entreprises des
tpe des pme des deux pays et je crois
qu'il faut aider ces entreprises qui
créent les emplois en territoire plutôt
qu'à rose et du sable justement anges et
en la vendant par les fenêtres auprès
des grandes multinationales qui ne font
que sa régie des rentes à l'exacte
solaire donc si l'on veut réussir je
crois qu'il faut que le président
république et puisse vraiment mettre le
paquet sur les tpe les pme et les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire et
nos artisans des commerçants travers
indépendant ce qui fait de l'impôt en
fait en france un quatrième vous croyez
que françois hollande va mettre le
paquet moi j'aimais la position de
laurent grandguillaume sur le fait de
passer à l'action parce que ça c'est
vrai problème que l'on rencontre en
france depuis un petit moment je
voudrais juste faire une métaphore ce
que je pense que ça va voir je vais
l'utiliser au cours du débat j'aimerais
vous parler de la voiture france en
france on on est dans un pays plutôt
ingénieux on l'a démontré encore à los
angeles avec les entreprises sur des
marchés nouveaux
donc on sait faire quelque chose qui
fonctionne plutôt bien mais vous savez
qu'une voiture pour qu'elle fonctionne
bien il ya un grand réseau électrique
qui relativement complexe et ça c'est le
maillage de l'eau difficultés
administratives de nombre de structures
qui peuvent exister qui font que cette
voiture a des fois du mal à fonctionner
correctement
mais dans une voiture pour qu'elle
fonctionne bien il faut un chauffeur ou
un conducteur est le problème que l'on a
lorsque nous avons pas bon conducteur
qui a tendance par exemple à piler sur
certaines dispositions par un
apprentissage tout à l'heure où accéléré
en matière d'emploi comme cela va être
présenté lundi
c'est que nous sommes tous passagers
cette voiture et lorsque vous avez un
conducteur de qualité moyenne voire
médiocre
qu'est ce que vous faites vous taisez
vous commencez à vous retrouviez vous
cramponner à la poignée et pour être un
peu vulgaire vous serrez les fesses
le problème aujourd'hui en france c'est
qu'on a une gouvernance qui accélère et
dufresne qui va à droite et à gauche qui
n'a pas un schéma des traces et pas de
visibilité et nous parce qu'aujourd'hui
je vous parle essentiellement qualité de
chef d'entreprise le critère premier
pour nous tous passagers
quel que soit notre niveau c'est la
confiance et lorsqu'à pas un climat de
confiance qui s'instaure sert quand vous
n'êtes pas une visibilité réelle
sur le chemin qui va être emprunté des
manières de faire vous avez peur et
quand vous avez peur vous êtes tentés de
changer de voiture est aujourd'hui dans
un marché international il ya des
voitures parallèle à nous lorsqu'on sait
que la troisième ville de france
c'est londres on comprend mieux pourquoi
certains français ont décidé de changer
de voiture
donc moi j'espère que lundi on aura des
positions claires durables qui
permettront de créer un climat de
confiance auprès des chefs d'entreprise
auprès des salariés également parce que
l'emploi c'est vital c'est le taux que
nous passons le plus dans une journée
ouvrable
c'est important d'être heureux dans ce
que l'on fait est que nos chefs
d'entreprise nous ayons une visibilité
sur les mesures qui vont être prises
puis les deux arbres nous on attendait
quelque chose de cette intervention de
ce plan ce plan d'urgence annoncé oui
j'aime déjà pas trop l'intitulé
d'urgence parce que comme l'a dit m ce
grand guillaume c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas dans une situation d'urgence on
connaît difficulté et le problème du
chômage depuis très longtemps donc le
plan mon avis aurait dû être amorcée
depuis très longtemps même s'il a déjà
été engagée dans le pacte de
responsabilité mais on y reviendra donc
oui nous on attend lundi un peu plus sur
les modalités
parce qu on sera vigilant sur sur la
manière dont ça va se décliner sur les
décisions qui seront prises le rideau
oui alors nous sommes ravis évidemment
de de ce plan d'urgence pour l'emploi
même si on est paré jeu de la façon dont
il va s'articuler en tous les cas la
volonté d'aider les pme et qui
représente 3 millions aujourd'hui les
entreprises françaises compte 253
grandes entreprises nationales par avoir
du sens 7 millions de salariés
c'est ce secteur marchand de l'économie
française qu'il faut valoriser et puis
il faut rendre compétitif pour recréer
de l'emploi
néanmoins je pense pas que ça passe par
des aides
les aides ont montré leur inefficacité
depuis des années
110 milliards d'euros des deux
entreprises distribuent aujourd'hui
certaines ont réussi à gommer les
imperfections budgétaire et bilanciels
liées à la crise mais ne permettent pas
aux entreprises de devenir compétitive
la position de la cgpme
elle est très claire c'est que ces 110
milliards d'euros on les arrête purement
et simplement et on les injecte dans des
baisses de charge durable c'est à dire
que
au lieu de saupoudrer des aides à
l'emploi qui vont pas rendre des
entreprises aujourd'hui efficace vaut
mieux s'inscrire dans une démarche qui
soit durable législatif qui baisse les
charges qui baissent le coût du travail
puisque ses 110 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui représente trois fois le
montant de l'impôt sur les sociétés ces
trois fois qui lui ne cesse de baisser
alors on a injecté 110 milliards d'euros
d'un côté et les résultats des
entreprises continuent de baisser donc
leur capacité à investir embaucher
baisse donc sur très pragmatiquement on
a montré les limites de ces aides
inscrivons nous dans une démarche
durable de baisse des charges de baisse
du coût du travail et les entreprises
deviendront compétitive pourront se
tourner vers l'international des grands
chercher les marchés 9 et d'abats valeur
ajoutée bon alors commençons par les
aides aux entreprises finalement voilà
j'avais prévu qu'on parle un peu
d'informations mais qu'est-ce que vous
engagez le sujet là dessus les aides aux
entreprises 110 milliards et monsieur
ville aux autres c'est une proposition
là de les effacer
pire que ça ce sont des milliards mais
c'est 6000 aide différentes en france
font 6000 est différent quand on cumule
celle de l'état et des collectivités
territoriales ambitieux rentrer dans des
cases pour avoir une aide et ceux qui
peuvent prendre du temps pour monter des
dossiers pour des êtres sont des grandes
entreprises par les tpe les pme qui ont
plutôt vocation à développer leur
chiffre d'affaires il ya commercialisé
bien sûr leurs produits ou leurs
services sans dire que le processus de
simplification l'a fait savoir à la saga
en plus qu'il ya une double peine dans
leur pays
quelle est la double peine c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on finance de la
robotisation par exemple pour créer des
lignes du futur mais on achète les
robots à l'étranger qui remplace le
travail humain c'est en fait en gros on
finance ce qui détruit de l'emploi et
qui en plus est produit à l'étranger
donc ce qu'ils font quand il ya des
aides elles peuvent exister parfois mais
il faut qu'elles soient ciblées sur la
création d'emplois et surtout réduire
leur volume
parce que ce qui pose pour les moins
d'entreprises c'est effectivement
notamment la fiscalité sur ces
entreprises parce que ce qu'ils payent
l'impôt en france ce sont d'abord les
petites entreprises les très grandes
entreprises
ils ont des cinémas d'optimisation
fiscale et elles sont en irlande
elles sont dans le nord de l'europe et
même des entreprises publiques nombreux
pays qui ont des filiales à l'étranger
j'avais demandé qu'une commission
d'enquêté leur sujet aux pays bas et qui
défiscalisent
à travers ses filiales on va dire
montmagny il faut qu'on arrête on peut
revenir vraiment aux tpe et aux pme et
aux au pays on peut d'ailleurs se
trouvait ça dramatique que le projet de
loi soit aujourd'hui tombé à l'eau de la
transparence
c'est un projet de loi qui a été portée
qui était beau temps qui a été en
première instance le 4 décembre et qui
par un rocambolesque jeu de vote accepté
dans un premier temps où le ministre du
budget a rappelé ses députés il était
jack 56 sont venus 47 pour finalement le
refuser ce projet de loi avait pour but
de pouvoir viser le nombre de filiales
les des bénéfices déclarés par les
grandes entreprises multinationales
françaises pour pouvoir combattre
l'évasion fiscale frauduleuses
on avait estimé que ça rapporterait 15
milliards d'euros dans les caisses de
l'état et que finalement ce projet doit
il a été abandonné avec avec un jeu un
jeu que nous ne comprenons pas tout à
fait ça parce qu'en fait il ya un
amendement qui est adoptée qui a permis
justement d'aller plus loin que ce qui
existait sauf qu effectivement le
ministre du budget s'est opposée
notamment sur une mesure qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre européen
donc ce n'est pas suffisant il faut
aller plus loin il faut convaincre le
gouvernement d'aller plus loin et
d'avoir de faire preuve d'audace en la
matière mais il a eu comme une avancée
et ce qui a été interprété par fois sur
la mesure où la loi de finances c'est
qu'il y aurait eu un abandon total
non il n'y a pas eu photo il ya eu une
avancée mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour
d autres il ya eu à voir modifier
effectivement d'un texte alors au nom oz
avec notamment le tweet que l'on vient
de voir je pense qu'on peut leur passer
mais ghislaine tu dis alors les patrons
alors c'est pas le cas de la celi permet
visiblement mais le medef en tout cas on
a entendu cette semaine demande encore
des aides notamment pour les pme
réclament encore des aides donc pourquoi
n'y at il pas plus de contrôle sur
comment est utilisé l'argent qu'on leur
donne pour la sécurité c'est ce que nous
demandons avant d'envisager quelques
redistribution de quelque forme que ce
soit c'est déjà de regarder ce qui a été
fait au niveau du pack de responsabilité
quand même
grosse somme d'argent et on sait qu'il
ya très peu d'entreprises qui ont il ya
très peu d'entreprises qui ont joué le
jeu
donc comment sont des gens déjà par
faire un bilan et peut-être réinjecter
effectivement de l'argent avec le
patronat qui jouent le jeu uniquement ça
c'est pas la solution de finances et
enfin en tout cas la cfdt ne voit pas
l'avenir comme ça c'est à dire c'est
c'est vraiment imaginer un nouveau
modèle économique
alors je vous entends la cgpme vous je
prends note que vous ne voulez pas dead
mais moins une charge mais au delà de ça
c'est quoi vos projets c'est quoi en
terme d'emploi ambiant le projet
l'emploi vous savez il est de toute
façon naturellement induits par une
santé des entreprises
si l'entreprise devienne compétitive
augmente le résultat se tourner vers de
nouveaux marchés parce qu'ils en ont les
moyens l on branche seront naturellement
si les marchés arrivent c'est vous
pouvez mettre toutes les aides que vous
voulez si les résultats des entreprises
continuent à chuter et si leur activité
baisse elles n'embauchent rompt pas
c'est pas ça le problème c'est pas les
aides qui vont créer l'emploi
c'est l'activité nouvelles les prises de
part de marché de nos entreprises les
prises de nouveaux marchés qui vont
générer de l' embauche et pour être
compétitif pour prendre ces marchés il
faut être compétitif vis-à-vis des
entreprises européennes qui sont nos
voisines
aujourd'hui les charges qui pèsent et je
terminerai par là sur les pme françaises
c'est 11,3 points de pib mondial
européen
en moyenne ces 5,2 points de pipe
comment voulez vous qu'on soit
compétitif et qu'on embauche à l'échelle
aujourd'hui mondialisées et on doit où
l'on doit faire émerger des grosses pme
et eti quissac qui s'exporte
voilà la vraie problématique de l'emploi
en france et c'est pas les aides qui
vont le résoudre la dame vandriesse mais
je skie ce qui est intéressant c'est
finalement toutes les tables on est
plutôt relativement ou d'accord c'est
pourquoi ça bouge pas vers l'art c'est
de ça dont je vais vous parler sur le
talent de gavray problème sûr que sur le
fait que finalement les dispositifs qui
ont été mis en place n'ont pas
fonctionné sur justin tableau je vous a
amené c'est l'évolution comparée des
pays de ces deux essentiellement repère
des charges sociales supportées y
compris liesse la faune c'est la 65
pourtant barrabes sur son compte après
65 % 65 % de chercheurs a pro compris
lorsque les pays concurrents le principe
aux deux
de la france si vous prendrez si vous
prenez l'allemagne ou l'angleterre soit
entre 10 et 15 points
sur le plan de charges inférieur donc la
complète la compétitivité et les mesurer
simplement par ce constat mais ce dont
on parle également parce que c'est de ça
dont il faut parler c'est qu'on est
toujours dans un agenda politique
prendre des dispositions louis c'est
réellement la difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on est dans un agenda politique
vous parlez madame vous avez raison on
l'a défendu à la région de l'évaluation
des politiques publiques et une
humiliation maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement difficile
parce que ce n'est pas une culture
française c'est le plus dur de tous les
autres pays et les pays européens ont
fait la réforme de paysans parce qu'ils
ont évaluée mesurer et donc changé et
quand je vous dis qu'il faut passer à
l'action
c'est passe à l'action sur ses réformes
de fou mais qui n'ont pas une mesure
politique immédiate
on le sait et qui n'auront pas une
mesure politique dans les 24 mois ou
dans les 18 mois
et c'est pour ça que je crains que le
plan d'urgence vous avez raison la
terminologie est quand même gravissime
sera certainement un plan qui permettra
à la marge d'un certain nombre de
créations d'emplois mais la difficulté
elle est pas là il y en a deux c'est
qu'on les en marché concurrentiel avec
une difficulté de charges sociales
charges supportées par nos entreprises
et la deuxième chose c'est que nous
sommes aujourd'hui de rentrer dans un
nouveau mode opératoire
vous savez qu aux etats-unis en 2001 45
% des actifs ne seront pas salarié la
création des trades et des métiers
nouveaux d'une part et des statuts
nouveau de travailleurs indépendants
c'est une réalité qui a la marge aussi
perturbent la vie et le fonctionnement
des entreprises
là où on aurait une différence c'est que
moi je ne crois pas non plus à un monde
sans règles c'est dire que pour moi il
faudrait un état il faut des services
publics sont les quais l'entreprise ne
pas développer à l'état efficace
bien sûr il faut les systèmes de
protection serré le seuil de retraite
par répartition l'assurance maladie bien
évidemment l'assurance chômage existe
après ce qu'il faut c'est mieux répartir
ses richesses et en même temps je crois
à réorienter les dépenses
on l'a dit par exemple qu'il ya trop de
public l'entreprise il faut moins de
fiscalité sont remplies ça c'est un
élément sur lequel il faut agir et après
il faut des protections différentes
on parle des travailleurs indépendants
par exemple chez les travailleurs
indépendants
que ce soit des entreprises auto
entrepreneurs des artisans et d'un
contrairement à ce que l'on pense il ya
plus de pauvreté chez les travailleurs
indépendants sur en proportion que chez
les sarries aujourd'hui bien sûr
pourquoi parce que ce sont des personnes
qui vont créer des structures banque sal
en fin de compte mais ils ont peu de
protection pas forcément de droit on
peut aussi raté on peut envoyer risme on
réussit pas forcément et donc à quelque
chose à inventer et je crois que il faut
là aussi dépasse les clubs donc moi je
pense qu'il faut à la fois des
protections pour les personnes et enfin
de la flexibilité d'entreprise et je
crois que si on arrive à concilier les
deux eh bien on aura un modèle qui peut
réussir mais juste pour ce que disait
catherine effectivement on voit qu'on
est premiers ou troisième dans le taux
de fiscalité supporter parce que c'est
toutes les charges
cis charge charges sociales tous
confondus et il a un peu sur les sur les
sociétés et en parallèle de ça on est le
dernier de la classe en est quasiment le
premier en taux de charge et dernier les
classes en valeur ajoutée sur nos
entreprises ou l'inde un taux de marge
tous secteurs confondus des entreprises
qui n'est pas le résultat net la marge
qui est ce qu'ils servent à couvrir les
charges de 28%
quand par exemple au royaume uni c'est
48% gilles après on n'a pas su ce que
vous regardez avantages sociaux pour les
37 sur la moyenne européenne
mais quand vous avez un taux de marge
qui est le plus faible d'europe et un
taux de charge qu'elle plus fort vous
comprenez bien que la compétitivité de
nos entreprises et les aider
complètement compromis de problème là
par rapport à l'an pose sur la question
avec 30 de notre compétitivité qui
existe après il ya un autre problème que
j'ai un peu évoquée c'est la question
doit aussi de l'automatisation saisir de
ce qui se substitue au travail
aujourd'hui dans la vérité on la parle
peu mais prendre l'exemple comme airbnb
blaquart et c'est mon présente ça comme
de l'économie collaborative cette bôme à
la mode c'est collaboratif
c'est pas collaboratif du tout ce sont
les entreprises et multinationales qui
sont pour la plupart dans la silicon
valley qui ont des schémas
d'optimisation fiscale qui détruisent de
l'emploi moi je préfère défendre nos
restaurateurs nous hôtelier tous ceux
qui justement créer de l'emploi dans les
territoires des emplois non
délocalisables lutter contre ces
nouveaux bus et pas de l'utc de régler
on a fait voter par exemple là c'était
en dehors des clivages cd votée à
l'assemblée et au sénat des amendements
pour prendre en compte par exemple eh
bien ces nouveaux revenus à travers ces
plateformes
parce qu'on était plate forme c'est quoi
en fait ils captent les richesses
il ya quelqu'un qui est au menu il ya
quelqu'un qui fait le menu celui qui
fait le menu c'est celui qu'elle pouvoir
c'est celui qui détient le capital
ce sont ces grandes entreprises mais à
la fin il ya quelqu'un qui souffrent et
ceux qui souffrent sur le terrain ce
sont justement nos commerçants nos
artisans qui sont captés par cette forme
qui n'ont plus aucune liberté
david entre ont détruit d'emplois mais
là il faut qu'on s'interroge hélas les
politiques qu'ils soient de gauche ou de
droite il doit vraiment s'interroger sur
ces sujets qui ne sont pas des sujets du
passé on n'est pas moi je ne suis pas
technophobes ou je ne sais quoi je pense
vraiment qu'il ya un sujet qui est posé
et prenons l'exemple en bourgogne de
kodak kodak et les ouvriers de kodak
doivent bien se souvenir un seulement
ceux qui ont perdu leur emploi ils ont
perdu leur emploi
justement chalon sur saône du fait d'une
rue d'une rupture technologique à
l'époque c'est bien le prêt et pose
encore aujourd'hui dans votre secteur
je devais revenir à titre si vous avez
raison sur l'exemple d'airbnb vous savez
que dans mon métier je suis agent
immobilier illustrateur de bien la loi à
l'urban duflot a eu des conséquences sur
la réglementation des loyers à paris
bon c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur marché immobilier à paris il on ne
loue plus dans le mode classique
transforme les appartements en
appartement airbnb je ne parle pas de la
fiscalité
évidemment qu'un vrai problème par
rapport à ça et au lieu d'avoir un
revenu foncier de x il n'oublie par 5 ou
par 10 résultat la loi a créé un billet
un système économique pas réellement
existant est là et aujourd'hui les
hôteliers souffrent parce que les
chambres d'hôtel ne sont pas réservés et
puis il ya une forme de dérive de
revenus font signe qu'ils sont pas
déclarés donc vous voyez les impacts
pose aujourd'hui de vraies questions sur
une évolution de la société c'est un
phénomène de fou un dernier mot juste
pour dire qu'effectivement on n'est pas
d'accord parce que je m'aperçois que
finalement on en revient par les
finances ce qu'on dit c'est que nous
c'est que la société elle change et
qu'il faut penser au monde de demain
automatisation tout ça c'est en train de
nous arriver là et on n'anticipe pas
c'est moi j'avais l'impression que ça
nous tombe dessus
non parce qu'on sait de l'automatisation
par contient j'ai juste un chiffre on
sait que 60% des métiers qui
embaucheront dans 20 ans ne sont pas
encore connus donc voilà après on a des
têtes pensantes qui sont capables
d'imaginer aussi le monde de demain
et puis devoir de prévoir les emplois
les formations donc il faut travailler
là dessus j'ai la grâce de france qu'une
partie de nos élites thèmes qui sont
déconnectés ce qu'en fait la politique
parfois devenu un métier puisque un
engagement et on n'a peut-être pas
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs par exemple
chez les élus m'ont été confiées mais
maintenant je pense mon autocritique
parce que moi même je suis conseiller en
formation mon métier à la base je sais
mon métier justement c'est pas la
politique et je suis pour le non cumul
des mandats en nombre dans le temps
c'est important aussi
il faut l'appliquer à faire voter des
lois supplémentaires mais par contre sur
cette déconnexion des élites si on n'a
pas beaucoup d'entrepreneurs chez les
élus on a aussi pas forcément beaucoup
de salariés et d'ouvriers par exemple
d'employés de professions intermédiaires
de cadres je suis alors nous travailler
aussi sur cette représentativité des
élus pour permettre aussi de faire
évoluer la société
et ça je crois un sujet qui est
important en rêvait j'en parlais d'eni a
travaillé il ya plus de 15 ans dans une
autre structure associative sur le
statut de l'élu en france
aujourd'hui je suis chef d'entreprise
mais imaginons que demain j'ai un
salarié qui souhaite s'engager en
politique
vous connaissez les agendas les sessions
c'est impossible je parle d'une tpe de
moins de 20 salariés
donc vous avez raison il ya un vrai
problème soit représentation nationale
ce problème n'a jamais été abordé ni par
la droite et par la gauche et du coup
cette déconnexion qui donne au sort
d'élections régionales des votes qui
peuvent être un peu populiste ou
populaires en tout cas l'an tout cas peu
plus dans la proche vient aussi sur
cette déconnexion qui existe et qui est
une réalité
vous allez rester allez on revient sur
la formation l'apprentissage vous
commencez à en parler
manuel valls a donc consulté les
organisations syndicales à lundi le plan
est encore un peu flou à l'action si on
la lui le chiffre de 500 milles
formation supplémentaire ça vous semble
à un chiffre réaliste ça sain sommes une
formation supplémentaire cela les moyens
actuellement avec force et je pense que
seriez sa condition
d'abord que toutes les collectivités
territoriales qui ont en charge pendant
cette compétence en pratique les régions
soient mobilisés sur tout le territoire
national bien sûr qu'il ya un vrai
travail qui soit organisée avec tous les
doutes notamment les autres cas qui
agite on a mené la formation à la guerre
du boulot je pense que des moyens on en
a qui font pas forcément bien affecté
parce que c'est long il ya la longueur
de la lenteur la lourdeur donc il faut
libérer aussi d énergie dans ce domaine
mais nous avons les capacités et
l'apprentissage aussi est une vrai
levier mais là aussi il faudrait que
pour une bonne fois pour toutes on se
pose et qu'on fixe les règles mois pour
tout et qu'on arrête de parler de
visibilité visibilité de modifier sans
cesse des règles et il faut passer et
moi je co président de conseil
simplification de l'entreprise on avait
défendu une mesure qui a été prise qui
est d'éviter justement de faire des
déclarations préalables pour autoriser
justement apprendre l'apprenti pente
mineurs mais plutôt un modèle déclaratif
simple il ya des vérifications a
posteriori ça il faut qu'on fasse
confiance à ses priorités prix a eu des
décrets qui ont été privés comment il
faut faire confiance priori aux
entrepreneurs contrôler a posteriori
bien évidemment s'il ya des abus et pour
libérer l'énergie parce qu'il ya
tellement de paperasse à remplir et de
documentation à 30 mètres que ça c'est
un peu compliqué pendant une question
aussi par rapport à l'apprentissage la
de paul pourquoi limiter l'apprentissage
aux jeunes de moins de 26 ans par
exemple pourquoi il ya des règles comme
ça et d'ailleurs il ya la présidente à
marie-guite dufay la présidente de
bourgogne franche comté qui a demandé
jeudi à manuel valls de pouvoir
expérimenter alors je la cite des
dispositifs innovants en matière
d'apprentissage d'orientation de
sécurisation et par exemple en reculant
l'âge limite est l'apprenti de 25 à 100
ça vous semblez vous permettez je vais
vous donner juste de quelques éléments
par exemple en angleterre et 850 mille
apprentis quand on n'arrive pas à 265
mille en france si on revient pas parler
du marché amm en marche arrière du
gouvernement mais en 2013 2014 sur
l'apprentissage est quand même des
allers-retours terrible aujourd'hui le
niveau d'apprentis en france et celui de
2005 à peine en angleterre et en
allemagne 3 fois plus 1 millions 33
cents mille apprentis en allemagne en
angleterre ce que les 858 l'apprenti 20
à 50 millions plus de 50 ans bon coup il
ya des choses à faire et à changer de
tri vite je reviens à ou cinq cent mille
formation sans principe pourquoi pas
dans les conditions qu'elle fixe et le
sua envier où je suis d'accord mais il
ya trois conditions à mes yeux pour cela
fonctionne il faut que la formation soit
de qualité
ce qui pose le problème de l'évaluation
des formations en france et la formation
des formateurs et la formation des
formateurs
la deuxième condition il faut qu'elles
soient adossées immédiatement à un stage
à une pratique à une pratique vous
faites pas faire de dépasser le cas là
maintenant c'est passé le cas mais ça ne
suffira pas à former les gens il faut
que derrière une pratique actuellement
chez moi dans mon entreprise j'ai deux
stagiaires 2 à titre gracieux parce
qu'ils sont dans des intérieurs ou trois
mois ils sont venus me voir parce qu'il
ne trouvait pas d'entreprises nous avait
déjà pris je les ai repris vous savez
dans les tpe pme qui sont l'essentiel
des entreprises qui prennent des
apprentis entre autres on est on fait du
compagnonnage ça se passe simplement
comme ça
voilà j'ai quelqu'un avec quelqu'un
d'autre qui travaillent et sur les 500
milles formation il faut s'assurer des
qualités formation il faut revenir sur
la formation des formateurs et il faut
qu'elles soient adossées tout de suite à
une activité professionnelle
si vous apprenez de la compta et de
l'anglais et que vous ne pratiquez pas
derrière ça passe ça ne sert à rien
consommé de la route est oui alors la
position de la cfdt sur le plan de
formation
déjà on le trouve très ambitieux mais
bon si on veut essayer d'arriver à
quelque chose de positif autant l'être
nous nos conditions et laurent berger
notre secrétaire général l'a déjà
adressé ses on veut que c'est formation
soit utile utile autant pour l'employeur
c'est à dire que va falloir réfléchir à
un groupe
mon avis un groupe de pilotage fort
régional de terrain pour qu'on puisse
concilier les besoins d'employeurs et
voilà et puis pour fixer les formations
de qualité et adapté en face pour que
les salariés soient employables j'allais
dire assez rapidement après la formation
j'en reparlerai aussi fan pour enfin je
vais vous dire que fait une proposition
aussi concernant le groupe de de
pilotage c'est peut-être de créer une
commission comme on a fait pour
commissaires ont reproduit vous avez des
voilà redressement productif qui serait
en capacité de piloter sur la région
voilà qu'on serait plus de sens pour
l'apprentissage vous connaissez
l'attachement de la cgpme sur
l'apprentissage pour les pme les pme
notre pays et de la côte-d'or en
particulier puisque l'action qu'on a vu
sur le cfa la noue l'année dernière
prouve notre attachement à
l'apprentissage cfa qui était proche du
dépôt de bilan on va le dire et qui
aujourd'hui est sauvé par notre apport
financier via notre autre cas donc ça la
condition là
sur les 500 mille le nombre moi j'ai pas
d'avis plus on sera miens formera avec
un emploi à la clé mieux ce sera donc je
suis passé spécialistes pour évaluer le
nombre
néanmoins pour pouvoir avoir besoin
d'apprentis on revient toujours à la
même problématique
il faut avoir d'activité ce que pour
former des apprentis de demain d'avoir
une vision pérenne de son entreprise et
d'évolution pour embaucher des gens si
on en a pas on prend pas d'apprentis
parce qu'on n'a pas besoin de main
d'oeuvre donc aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage hélios et une économie
de fonds qui doit aller mieux et
l'apprentissage repartira syli a
également eu un mieux être des
entreprises concernant moi je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui l'apprentissage
il est idéal aussi en difficulté par
rapport à des pays comme l'allemagne
parce que en allemagne vous avez des
métiers dont dont l'occupation ne peut
être fait que par la voie de
l'apprentissage l'apprentissage est une
voie d'excellence vers ce métier
en france on n'a pas ça on peut être on
peut effectuer un métier par différentes
voies donc l'apprentissage est aussi une
voie d'excellence vers l'emploi c'est
d'ailleurs un peu dit madame elle comme
les professeurs avaient déclenché les
pires lever les contraintes sur
certaines branches pour l'accès d'un
apprenti à un métier puisque quand on
regarde dans le tp dans le bâtiment les
contraintes on peut pas monter sur un
escabeau à plus de 3 et ça ça a changé
mais c'était ça aujourd'hui c'était ça
comment voulez vous apprendre un métier
sans l'exercer
c'est compliqué mais c'est pas ça le
principal frein le principal frein c'est
et je vais terminer par là c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on doit orienter des
jeunes et des moins jeunes parce que
l'apprentissage plus loin c'est pas
grave mais sur l'apprentissage dès le
collège et arrêter de vouloir leur faire
des bacheliers à tout prix et est allé
et les orienter vers des emplois qui
existent à les hameaux de réponse il
nous reste une minute avant la pause
moi ce que je veux dire si ce serait
bien qu'on défende les droits
des personnes des femmes et des hommes
plutôt que les droits des structures en
fait qu'on soit porteur de droit la
formation en fait mais que l'on puisse
sortir de toutes ces structures de
toutes ces tuyaux tri de remettre à
chaque fois chaque personne est
confrontée en fin de compte à des usines
à gaz sont des usines à gaz
c'est sans doute parce qu'en fait il
faut seulement il faut revenir à la
personne à l'humain c'est comme ça qu'on
apporte des réponses
il faut arrêter de toujours protéger des
structures les organismes gèrent il faut
arrêter il ya des signes des injustices
et des inégalités parce que des
personnes ne rentrent pas dans quelle
case or elles peuvent en droit des
formations retrouver un emploi si on
sort de ses cages financier
d'apprentissage entre les complexités et
vous gré de la liberté vous avez raison
il faut arrêter le collège unique obligé
des enfants aller jusqu'au bout du
collège unique alors qu'aujourd'hui on
le sait qui fonctionne en allemagne il
ya des voies l'apprentissage qui
existent d'excellence qui permettent
aussi des licences professionnelles par
la suite et c'est là se souvient de la
liberté merci on va se retrouver dans
une poignée minutes le temps d'une
courte pause vous retrouvez le flash qui
est présenté aujourd'hui par pauline
ringenbach hambourg